hey hime wits I'm a senior fellow at the
Manhattan Institute and contributing
editor at City Journal
the bourgeois family was extremely child
centered and the the the purpose of the
family was to teach child the child not
just to love the child of course there
was that but also to teach the child the
kinds of habits and values that would
allow them to try to thrive in their
free market economy so the children had
to learn self-discipline they have to
learn to be motivated to they have to
learn to be creative and inquisitive
they have to learn to be competent these
are these are fairly advanced skills
that require many many years of
socialization this is why we always had
this idea of a long childhood and a long
protected childhood where the child
would gradually learn to take on more
and more responsibilities become more
and more autonomous so that they could
then go on to lead independent creative
and fulfilling law and and loving lives
but the market introduces all sorts of
noise that makes this process extremely
difficult one is that the child is told
to or is is tempted with so many
different objects of desire food and
toys and in sexual information thinks
that they are maybe not quite ready to
process our having trouble controlling
themselves in in the face of this is I
you know you have so much more energy
that parents are forced to bring to bear
on socializing Charlotte under those
circumstances so the free market makes
that process very difficult it also
attempts adults to it isn't just the
kids the free market tells us the market
in the open market tells us that there
all sorts of desires that we can satisfy
that maybe we didn't even know we had
and makes possible lives of affluence
that ore is beta this is a wonderful
thing but it also means that we are
capable of a kind of a autonomy that
people in previous ages were not well
I've been writing for many years now
about children's development and then
been very aware of how difficult it is
to raise children in modern America I
gather this is also true in other parts
of the Western world these days and one
of the things that I came up with in my
early research was the problem of the
media which is an extension of the free
market I and the way that the free
market gets introduced to the young
child particularly through television
and a lot of people are very much aware
of how difficult television in
particular now the internet this was not
so much the case when I first started
writing it complicates the job of
socializing a child so when I was
presented with this question of does the
free market corrode moral character I
thought to myself well what I do know is
that it makes socializing children makes
moralizing children an extremely
difficult job
well interestingly enough despite the
fact that the market has made
socializing children so much more
difficult it despite the fact that it
you know introduces your five-year-old
to Paris Hilton and grand theft auto it
also has the effect of increasing
parental supervision shall we say it's a
funny thing because there was a time in
that's in the 1980s when I was first
starting to concern myself with the
question of what it was like to raise
children in the in contemporary society
we were hearing a lot more about the
latchkey child the child who was really
left home alone remember that that
series of movies was based on a real
sense in the culture that children were
indeed home alone and in fact something
different happened by the early to late
90s where parents kind of redoubled
their efforts to supervise their kids
despite the fact that they were spending
many many more hours at work when you
combine mothers and fathers work hours
nevertheless they found ways men talking
largely middle-class parents who had the
material wealth to do this they
introduced all sorts of afterschool
activities surrogate tutors certain you
know surrogates supervisors like tutors
and babysitters and so forth and then of
course we got cell phones which have
provided a kind of umbilical cord
between parents and children and at this
point I find that I'm in touch with my
youngest child who is a internet and
cell phone baby all the time far more
than that my parents were in touch with
me or that I was in touch with my older
kids when they when they were growing up
so I think that you know in ways that I
never could have predicted I don't think
anybody could have the bourgeois family
has sort of reinforced its efforts
- to really pay attention to the
socialization of the next generation
this has been a much harder thing for
people with fewer resources - to handle
well I like to think that we can correct
the the corruption of the free market I
think that in many ways we're doing a
pretty good job as I you know I've been
writing for some years now
I think the middle-class Americans you
know I have a lot of criticisms of hyper
parenting and parents who are not taking
their children's more alive that
seriously that sort of thing but you
know when we look at how those kids are
doing I think we can be pretty pretty
proud I also have some complaints about
the education system and the
particularly ecologists and I'm not
happy with the way their cognitive
development is going should I say but
clearly we're not doing as good a job
for our people with fewer resources and
whether or not we can undo that problem
is is remains to be seen I think that
people who are blessed with family with
middle-class lifestyles with intact
families need to understand just how
lucky they are and to try to think about
ways to pass on the good news because
there is a real reluctance that I see in
my generation but even more in the next
generation to cast any judgment and
therefore to make any recommendations
about family structure and this
reluctance to discuss this problem it
seems to me is going to only worsen our
progress with inequality